sensation sensations le mag
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
sensation en partenariat avec tv
soixante dix huit pour la saison 2010 21
2022 le théâtre coluche à plaisir
souhaite proposer de la découverte du
divertissement et du rire pour en parler
avec nous je reçois aujourd'hui florence
k - directrice du théâtre bonjour
bonjour alors après une saison 2009 1 2
mille 21 difficile il semblerait que la
culture et l'art du spectacle puisse
réellement reprendre du service alors
quelles sont vos ambitions pour cette
nouvelle saison mais mon ambition
principal c'est d'avoir beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de public que les gens
viennent ensemble tous au théâtre et
puis enfin rassuré enfin heureux qu'ils
puissent vivre plein d'émotion ça c'est
mon ambition la plus grande est alors
avec beaucoup de spectacles annulés lors
de la saison précédente est ce que vous
avez fait le choix d'en re programmer le
plus grand nombre est ce que vous avez
voulu vous préférez sur de la nouveauté
alors c'est un mix en fait il ya une
vingtaine de spectacles qui ont pu être
reportés la saison dernière on a un
petit peu fonctionné de septembre à
octobre est un petit peu en juin donc on
a eu un petit peu de place qui s'est
libérée il ya aussi des artistes qui
n'ont pas souhaité reprendre la tournée
de leur spectacle qui sont passés à
autre chose donc au milieu de cette
vingtaine de spectacles reportés on a
une quinzaine de nouveautés qui me
tiennent vraiment très à coeur alors
justement on va parler de la
programmation de votre spectacle pour le
mois de septembre et octobre on va
commencer avec le 14 septembre c'est un
spectacle spécialement pour les abonnés
alors de quoi s'agit-il alors en fait
l'idée c'était de d'offrir un spectacle
à nos abonnés et on nous avons eu la
chance et nous avons la chance
d'accueillir macha méril en résidence à
partir du 8 septembre pour une
représentation qu'elle offre à tous nos
abonnés le 14 septembre elle vient
répéter elle relance ce spectacle qui
avait été créée au poche montparnasse et
qui après repart au poche montparnasse
donc l'idée c'est que si vous prenez si
vous achetez au moins eu 6 6 places pour
six spectacles différents sur pour une
personne vous pouvez avoir ce septième
spectacle offert et je précise aussi que
en fait vu tout ce qui s'est passé
l'abonnement ça devient un abonnement 20
à 22 sur deux ans c'est à dire que
toutes les places que vous avez déjà que
vous allez garder vous attendez depuis
des mois et des mois de voir enfin le
spectacle que vous avez choisi ça compte
dans l'abonnement avec les nouveautés ou
leur achat de places pour des spectacles
reportés alors on va on va que
poursuivre le 17 septembre à 20h30 le
spectacle j'ai des doutes que nous
réserve cette soirée alors là c'est le
grand grand françois morel qui revisite
raymond devos à sa manière avec son et
son humour son et de son état d'esprit
sa voix aussi parce que c'est un
chanteur un musicien c'est un humoriste
donc la sinne une soirée de pur délice
pour renouer avec raymond devos que qui
est restée dans les mémoires alors on va
écouter un extrait maintenant de j'ai
envie de toi qui sera du coup en
spectacle le 21 septembre on écoutait on
en parle juste après d'accord
[Musique]
on connaît
pas
de son côté
parce que la dernière qu'aucun m'a dit
qu'elle rime copine qui l'attendait en
bas avec un bac l'an
ça doit être un fantasme avec de la
nourriture
on
m'a raconté votre fric je louais des
pommes de terre et de la mort
grâce à de bons vins sont alliés aussi
c'est complètement inutile mais juste
savourer on va surtout pas vous
contrarier
allez c'est parti
c'est pas possible d'être aussi con
les vieux les dimanches cristal
olemps culé
oui elle aussi
mais les lumières jaloux monde hier il
est entier c'est la gueule
pour ed
colas a dit me prendre un coca
[Musique]
alors j'ai envie de toi une pièce de
sébastien castro pouvez vous nous en
faire un petit synopsis un petit résumé
finalement de cette pièce alors déjà je
voulais dire c'est la première pièce de
sébastien castro et c'est une vraie
réussite moi j'ai pu la découvrir au
théâtre fontaine c'est juste une série
de quiproquos alors évidemment sébastien
castro se plaît à jouer un abruti
complet qui ne comprend rien sauf qu'il
a un voisin de palier qui a beaucoup de
maîtresses et enfin il en a au moins
deux et il voudrait se séparer de
l'ancien et accueillir chez lui une
nouvelle sauf que son voisin va lui
mettre une pagaille totale dans sa vie
privée il lui n'arrive pas à s'en sortir
et bas prix je peux pas raconter parce
qu'il ya tellement d'enchaînements on
croit qu'on va se perdre mais sébastien
casseront réussi à ne jamais nous perdre
c'est à dire qu'on comprend pourquoi
sébastien castro est perdu dans une dans
cette situation qui enchaîne les
quiproquos et c'est hyper drôle c'est un
éclat de rire toutes les 20 secondes
allait le mieux c'est d'aller voir la
pièce le 21 septembre on continue avec
le spectacle des plans sur la comète le
25 septembre encore une comédie avec une
pointe d'émotion c'était important
d'offrir du rire aux spectateurs pour
cette nouvelle saison en tout cas pour
ce début de nouvelle saison on a besoin
de rire là on a besoin de plus penser à
rien qu'au plaisir de la vie donc des
plans sur la comète déjà c'est un
spectacle qui a été reportée qui était
prévu la saison dernière que j'ai que je
n'ai pas revu cet été à avignon mais qui
a fait un énorme carton au festival
d'avignon qui revient donc nourri et
enrichi de toute cette vie puisque
finalement fini tous ces spectacles ont
2 2 ce sont des créations à la base mais
qui n'ont pas retrouvé le public est là
les artistes ont retrouvé le public donc
ça donne une dimension spectacle une
jubilation des comédies des comédiens
qu'on qui donne une intensité encore
plus grande à l'humour et l'a donc
tristan petitgirard a écrit cette pièce
sur l'histoire d'une jeune fille qui une
savante savante spécialiste des étoiles
et son papa étant tout aussi grand
savant sauf qu'ils sont fâchés ensemble
parce qu'ils sont pas d'accord sur sur
leur métier quoi et le problème c'est
que la meilleure lui l'école c'est le
papa sauf qu'ils tombent amoureux de la
meilleure copine de sa fille est là ça
m'est déjà comme ils sont fâchés mais là
ça crée une dimension supplémentaire
dans la fâcherie et ça crée un gros
problème pour la pop in très drôle et
début octobre c'est à un spectacle une
nouveauté encore plus haut que le ciel a
expliqué noah alors plus haut que le
ciel s'est on retrouve en fait moi j'ai
retrouvé le plaisir que j'avais il ya
des années en voyant les palmes de
monsieur foot je sais pas si ça vous
parle et c'est humoristique
c'est aux romantiques et on apprend
plein de choses parce que la
construction de la tour eiffel c'était
pas une évidence et surtout pas pour
buste avait fait donc voilà on a le
plaisir de l'historique de l'humour et
du romantisme parce qu' une belle
histoire d'amour alors en parlant d'
humour ou vous accueillez jérémy ferrari
le 5 octobre qui jouera son son show
anesthésie générale par c'est important
pour vous aussi de d'invités finalement
des grands noms du show un ben alors
jérémy ferrari moi j'avais vu à son
précédent spectacle qui avait fait un
gros quart entre carton vendeuse pièce à
beyrouth déjà un petit peu prémonitoire
et là il nous parle des médicaments et
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques l'était
aussi dans un il est comme dans un
esprit très lié à l'actualité et puis
les d'une causticité il est aussi dans
la dénonciation certes de certaines
choses voilà ça fait partie des grandes
de l'humour un jérémy ferrari d'ailleurs
c'était complet mais rassurez-vous les
jo j'étais limité qu'en savez quand nous
avons annoncé que c'était complet et là
on peut remplir la salle donc bientôt il
ya plein de places qui vont apparaître
sur le web précipitez vous faudra pas
faudra pas manquer l'occasion le 9
octobre les spectateurs pourront
participer à un concert de jazz avec
richard et charlie tributaire nommage de
l'artiste hureaux sphérique reprendre
durée de charme ça peut être très
compliqué est-ce que hiros perry tient
sa promesse à travers ce concert ah oui
je les ai vus plusieurs fois ce concert
déjà la fille de richard
absolument adoré il a une voix il est
absolument confondant cet artiste
d'ailleurs il fait été tournées dans le
monde entier depuis je suis pas plus de
dix ans avec avec ce tribut torride
charles et en plus on a le plaisir
d'avoir une vraie équipe de musiciens
exceptionnel avec lui et les choristes
les paires lettre ce qu'il appelle les
perlette puisque rose peric perlette
voilà et du coup oui c'est un très très
grand concert vous allez pack déçu vous
allez retrouver sa part et giles est
charles c'est unique au monde mais
franchement c'est bluffant alors
justement on a vu un petit peu de rire
du concert de la découverte des
nouveautés comment est-ce que vous
choisissez justement cette programmation
est ce que c'est avant tout des coups de
coeur alors d'abord ce sont des coups de
coeur moi je vois plus de 200 spectacles
par an d'ailleurs au festival d'avignon
cet été j'en ai vu une centaine je ne
lâche pas la faire donc je n'ai pas
trouvé des spectacles que j'ai vraiment
envie de revoir qui m'ont passionné non
je suis capable de me souvenir et de
dont je suis par capa vous voyez j'ai
pas de notes devant moi je suis capable
d'en parler pendant des années c'est des
vrais coups de coeur c'est pas comme ça
il faut faire de la musique faut faire
de l'humour il faut faire du théâtre non
c'est juste que ces spectacles chez
envie de les partager avec le public de
plaisir donc voilà j'ai envie qu'ils
ressentent ça et qu'il puisse m'en
parlait à la sortie et qu'ils soient
heureux donc voilà c'est pour ça je fais
ce métier pour ça
et pour retrouver justement la
programmation ça se passe sur le site tc
tirer plaisir point fr merci beaucoup
plus haut risque à moins d'avoir été
avec m sur sensations et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez vous sur
notre site et applications radio
sensations
et